I am joined today by Scott Adams the
creator of the world-famous Dilbert
comic strip which I've been reading
shockingly since I was 11 years old also
author of many many books a lot of which
I've read and in what kind of bums me
out I think a trump supporter and we're
going to talk to him about whether he
believes Trump is a great influencer or
believes in the Trump agenda or the
Trump message etc thanks for doing this
by the way I know that that we we maybe
started off Rockley on twitter with me
criticizing your report card which we'll
get to but I appreciate you being
willing to have a conversation about it
it's a pleasure thanks for having me so
let's sort of start at the beginning
your politics aside from Trump do you
characterize yourself as a left or right
winger libertarian authoritarian what
are your personal politics
I've been calling myself an ultra-left
in other words ultra ultra liberal left
of Bernie and what I mean by that is I
like a lot of the stuff he likes for
example I like free college I like
health care for everybody but Bernie
didn't have a practical plan to get
there I think we should make a practical
plan and it probably has something to do
with changing our systems and using
technology and you know focusing on
startups that can lower costs and that
sort of thing but where I want to go is
is good for everyone you know I'd like
to get the same things Bernie wants but
I don't think he had a plan to get there
so like for example on economic justice
as one issue and taxation since we're
dealing today with the passage of this
new tax bill would I be correct to to
presume that if you are with Bernie or
to the left of Bernie that this is a tax
plan that you don't see as a good tax
plan for the country yeah I'm not in
support of the tax plan I would have I
would have just left it very similar to
how it was and just dropped some of the
the tax rates for the people in the
middle you probably did have to do
something for the corporate tax rates
just to be competitive I think that
argument is sound economically and and
in the long run that's going
be good for everybody if the
corporations are doing well even if that
feels a little distasteful yeah well
let's I actually in part two of the
interview we'll dig into that specific
part because I know that plays into your
economy grade for Donald Trump's report
card of his first year so historically
what political candidates have you
tended to vote for in support
well my most recent as in as in the last
several elections philosophy is to not
vote and the reason I do that is because
as a student of persuasion which I
assume we'll be talking about in more
detail yeah I've learned that as soon as
you join a team you sacrifice all
objectivity now you may not do that
intentionally but the the normal way a
human being is wired is that the moment
you say I'm on this team you start
defining everything your team does as
wonderful and right and everything the
other team does as stupid and evil and
it's sort of automatic so as soon as you
vote for somebody or join a team and I'm
neither Democrat nor Republican I don't
think I'm registered at this point it
gives you at least a chance of
objectivity even though there's a lot
more to it but it's yeah you know it's
interesting you mentioned that because
that's exactly what I think is a
criticism what of what happened to
Donald Trump in other words growing up
he was relatively apolitical in some
sense but but I guess putatively a
Democrat and he donated to people on
both sides of the aisle he decided I
believe because he only had a chance of
winning the Republican primary he never
would have won the Democratic primary
now he's a Republican Republican good
Democrat bad isn't the reason that you
have not voted historically a really
good criticism of the problem of what
we've seen with Trump since he has
declared I am a Republican could you say
more about that are you saying that he's
embraced too much Republican philosophy
no I think he has no idea about
Republican philosophy if he did that I
would actually respect that more what
he's embraced is just what Republicans
tell him is good is what's good and
Chuck Schumer and Nancy Pelosi are
terrible people anything that they've
proposed historically
is bad Democrats are bad Republicans are
good when when really that's not been
his lifelong philosophy it seems he has
fallen victim to exactly what you're
pointing out which is once he joined the
team he lost all objectivity I think it
would be hard to say that one of the
things I always caution against his
mind-reading strangers so so what you're
suggesting would would imagine that you
have some insight into his inner
thoughts
no necessarily I'm just saying from ways
public statements it's everything
Democrats do and have done and proposes
bad and he's a Republican and we need
the Doug Jones
we need Doug Jones to lose because we
need the seat with no regard to to what
that actually means that's what I mean
that's what I mean yeah let me make a
distinction between what a politician
believes in their inner thoughts versus
how they act because that you have to
act a certain way to get a certain
result okay so I think it's hard to
distinguish how much of President Trump
or indeed any politician how much of
what they say is to get the effect and
how much is what they they really
believe deeply on the inside now I have
a little more faith in someone who has
ever changed sides so for example the
fact that he was once a Democrat but now
a Republican gives me a little hope that
he's at least had some appreciation for
both sides
likewise when I look at the the lawyers
on TV talking about the Russia collusion
and whether there's something there or
now something there I've put far more
credibility in Alan Dershowitz because
he was a Clinton supporter who doesn't
see a crime at least one committed by by
a Trump so so I feel a little more
comfortable you can't be a hundred
percent comfortable with anybody else's
objectivity
but whatever you see somebody cross a
line like that that should give you a
little bit of hope strictly speaking
though that's lodged that's a logically
fallacious way to assess the
believability of a claim though right
the fact that someone has revised a
claim says nothing whatsoever about the
truth of the claim I mean someone who at
one point believed that climate change
was caused by humans now has been
influenced by this so
skeptic community and no longer believes
it the merely the fact that someone has
held two opinions and believes that
they've come to the eventual correct
assessment from a from a strictly
speaking logical standpoint tells us
nothing about the truth of their belief
that's correct okay that it only it only
tells you that they may be the type of
person who is capable of changing an
opinion which is actually special in its
own way because you know you can see
online on Twitter people won't change
their opinion because the facts changed
sure is it's a rare situation yeah
Daniel Simon's work on this subject and
Dan Ariely both very very very
interesting and in terms of people
becoming further entrenched in their
beliefs actually right so let's get to
your thoughts about Trump I mean I know
that ultimately I think you at different
points endorsed like four different
people in the last election and Hillary
Clinton you said you did because you
were getting death threats after not
endorsing her is that right well I I had
not in the beginning I didn't endorse
anyone I was just trying to be as
objective as possible and but I was
writing about president Trump's powers
of persuasion not his politics but his
ability to persuade and the tools he was
using based on my background as a
trained hypnotist for for anybody who
was following this and doesn't know my
background yeah and but that was enough
of an endorsement in other people's eyes
to say okay you're just a Trump
supporter that wasn't exactly the case
in my case but it was close enough that
people said okay you're on that side
once they said that
and once the Democrats had built a good
persuasion case that Trump was not just
a candidate they didn't like but
actually the second coming of some kind
of a Hitler Nazi type of personality
that gave people moral cover to kill him
and to kill me and I mean that literally
is if you actually if you think somebody
is well he reminds me of Hitler that's
not permission to kill it but if you say
he is Hitler sure like he's actually
going to do the things Hitler does he's
going to round up brown people because
the investor sort of talked you were
hearing
so under that condition you do have
moral permission to murder
they actually literally murder somebody
who is actually Hillier
because if an actual Hitler was coming
up and you as a citizen had a chance to
take him out well you ought to do it
right okay so you're sort of naming some
hyperbolic statements that would not get
you to oppose Trump but what I would
have bet what eventually I would like to
get to and you mentioned the persuasion
aspect you know in reading a lot of what
you've written about your feelings about
Trump it definitely seems that you are
sort of impressed with Donald Trump's
persuasion skills as you describe them
but I'm curious why you think that
that's a value in and of itself
well tools have to be evaluated as tools
so when I look at my tool box and see
the hammer it might be a really good
hammer for pounding a nail but that
doesn't mean I need to pound a nail it
doesn't mean that a nail needs to be in
anything it just means that's a good
tool so the tools that the president
uses are the same tools that we citizens
can use in our daily life to also to
good effect if we're good people and
that effective were bad people that's
how tools work and so I thought it was
important for people to understand the
president in terms of the tools he had
because they were the ones he would
bring to the job if elected and that and
there would be the most predictive
element of everything you're seeing is
the the power of those persuasive tools
so I thought people needed to know that
and that's and I thought people would be
or I hoped people would be adult enough
to understand that you can you can
compartmentalize a complicated person
and say well he is doing this part right
and well even if you don't like all
these other parts yeah and I you know I
think we actually have some agreement on
this I I see it as Donald Trump was able
to bamboozle a significant portion of
the population with for example populist
rhetoric even though as we see from the
tax bill that he's governing in quite a
different way talking about I'm going to
keep you safe with this wall that Mexico
is going to pay for who's even talking
about that anymore
it was laughable to even believe it
would happen when he was talking about
it that it's it's deep in the rearview
mirror at this point so I don't know if
you I agree with you that he was able to
persuade people and now the more
governance time we get the more I'm
convinced that it was a bamboozling of
people into making them think that he
would do things I've never really had an
intention of doing what do you think but
let me let me ask you a definition yeah
how do you define the difference between
leadership and bamboozling how do you
make that distinction I don't know that
there are two terms that are sort of I
don't know why it's those two terms I
see them as two totally unrelated things
bamboozling is sort of like a scam
scamming people making them think you're
going to a be leadership is lead oh
there's no no but it's the same set of
tools you're persuading somebody to go
in a certain direction I I would I would
submit that the difference between
leadership that you like and bamboozling
that you don't is whether you think is
heading in the right direction no I
don't think so let me tell you why I
don't think so okay if Donald Trump had
proposed a set of policy ideas that I
disagreed with and then carried them out
that wouldn't be bamboozling I would
still disagree with it but it's not
bamboozling merely because I don't agree
with it so I reject that idea I think
the bamboozling is that he promised one
thing and is doing another that he
framed himself as this populist who's
going to do all these things that will
be great for the average person and yet
most of those things either haven't been
done or he's no longer even interested
in doing them well you would agree that
in the case of the wall just his talking
tough about immigration has probably
lowered the rate of people wanting to
immigrate in other words immigration is
lower is would you agree with that well
I would agree that for many years more
people have been leaving the u.s. to go
back to Mexico than coming in but that's
a trend that precedes Trump deportations
are actually down under Trump compared
to Obama so if you have a metric to
point to I'd be curious to hear it but
every metric I've see is that hoser
we've got a net outflow to Mexico for
years and that deportations are down
trunk die I agree that we've had in that
outflow for years but we've also had a
greater a greater reduction in
immigration since the election that's
what the news is reporting is that wrong
when you say the news is reporting I
immediately am skeptical because I want
to be as critical a reader of the news
as possible if you had specific data we
could talk about it I think neither one
of us necessarily has it in front of us
well let's let's make that a fact check
for the audience absolutely that both
that both sides and I think we'd agree
there there are two sides of the media
right there's the conservative and the
liberal side I believe both sides are
reporting a big increase a big decrease
in immigration that they do tie to about
election day that that there seemed to
be a change about that okay now that
aside ago I mean big picture do you I
know that the persuasion skills of Trump
have been a big a big element in your
beat being sort of impressed with him
but in terms of the governance and
without getting into the the micro which
will do in part two how do you think
he's doing as a leader of the United
States he's what I call a pricey
president and by that I mean in order to
get the good stuff you're gonna have to
pay and you may not be paying in money
so one of the things that is definitely
on the negative side is racial feelings
so I would say that one of the things
that is a cost of the Trump presidency
is that we have worse feelings about
race than we really need to you know the
the the world events don't really
support how badly people are feeling
about race at the moment and a lot of
that may be all of it is on him directly
so I give him an F grade for racial you
know racial happiness yeah we agree now
now he might be able to improve that and
I think you will and I've been working
specifically with black lives matter of
New York to see if I can you know help
make some change happen there that's a
separate story now but if you're if
you're looking at other elements
he seems to do them unusually well so
for example I think that dealing with
North Korea it's or too early to say but
it's very likely that his style will be
unusually effective because he's a
little bit scarier he's a little bit
less predictable and he'll probably take
things further than other people would
take them and he's also made made
friends with the people that maybe
traditionally we weren't so friendly
with Putin and I'll say and she in China
a little slightly different situation
there but he seems pretty he seems to be
on good terms with them because he's
made an expensive decision apparently
alright I'm not trying to mind-read it
just based on what we say apparently
he's taking the expense of being friends
with dictators or you know powerful
people of let's say adversary
adversarial countries some of us are
going to deal with yeah and and in order
to deal with this what he would consider
a larger priority in this case North
Korea so if you're asking me is it
expensive to have a president Trump I
would say oh yeah it's gonna cost you
this doesn't come free you know he's got
some rough edges and and nobody thinks
he doesn't need to deal with them but
but the big stuff like the economy North
Korea dealing with Isis he seems to be
nailing the big stuff even if you allow
that President Obama gave us and I do
allow this that he gave us a strong base
so in other words the economy was doing
well I believe seventy-five percent of
what we've seen in this past year is
really an Obama economy just carried
over and by the way I think Obama did a
great job of taking us back from the
brink of financial disaster when he when
he first came into office he was the
right personality for that kind of
situation but now we have a good economy
and the right kind of personality to
take it to an even greater level is the
super optimist the person who can talk
the economy up so those those same
things that you call bamboozling and
maybe people call a conman and I would
call leadership if it's heading in the
right
he he is doing directly for the economy
which is largely a psychology engine so
if you don't have shortages which would
describe you know 2017 we didn't have
shortages of really anything it's how
you feel about the economy that makes
you invest or not hire or not and he's
he's operating directly on that level of
our psychology and you can see that all
the metrics that speak to the psychology
of the economy are just off the charts
now horribles that on that note I think
that's a good place for us to pause and
we'll jump directly in part two of the
interview into the meat of the report
card including the economy and other
factors we're speaking with scott adams
the creator of the world famous Dilbert
comic strip we will be back with part
two we're continuing our conversation
with scott adams creator of the world
famous Dilbert comic strip author of
many many books many of which i've been
reading since i was a little kid quite
frankly let's pull out now something
else that you've written scott i have
the trump report card of what is
effectively the first close to first
year in front of me and i want to pick
up on some of the issues you mentioned
in part one of the interview
you've been talking you've mentioned a
couple times now that you think it is an
economically good thing to reduce the
corporate tax rate i think you even said
in part one of the interview that it's
undeniable that economically that is a
good thing can you explain why reducing
the corporate tax rate is good for the
economy in the case of economics in the
case of cutting the corporate tax rate i
look to other experts other economists
too to give me an opinion on that and
there seems to be a general consensus be
it's not a hundred percent but
economists seem to agree that we need to
be more competitive with our corporate
structures and that other countries have
lower tax rates and this would make us
competitive now i have a degree in
economics and and an mba from from
berkeley top business school and but i
wouldn't use my own expertise in this
case because i think you did some fairly
specific expertise in this this micro
area but the experts seem to agree that
and even some democrats seem to have
said yeah that corp
rates a little high now the question of
how you pay for it in terms of the
deficit is it related but still separate
question but before we go to that here's
where I want to drill down big and I
want to see where you and I have because
I also have a degree in economics and an
MBA although arguably from not as
prestigious of an association as your
your degree is from forgetting about the
how to pay for it part you reduce the
tax on corporations great how exactly
does that improve the economy well the
idea is that if corporations have more
money they will invest more they'll hire
more people and and those changes you
know work their way into the economy now
if you're arguing that there might be a
more direct way to do it as in giving
the benefit directly to let's say the
middle class because they would spend a
hundred percent of everything you gave
them because they're they're operating
on the edge yeah whereas the
corporation's the corporation's might
just give themselves bigger paychecks
and you know give the executives more
money and a lot of stuff you don't like
but I think it's generally true that
corporations who have resources are the
ones that are going to they're gonna
have a bigger R&D budget because they
can afford it they're gonna be a little
kinder to their employees a little
better healthcare because they can
afford it
so I don't think anybody doubts in
general that if corporations have more
resources that some of that will we'll
see seep into the economy yeah the
problem oh and I may be you've not heard
this before but the problem with that is
the following when you reduce the
corporate tax rate what you're basically
reducing is the cost of earning profits
right because the investments in capital
the investments in employees that's all
tax deductible in other words any of
those investments that you make reduce
the tax you pay if the tax rate is 35%
versus 21% your savings by reinvesting
in your company is significantly larger
so at an economic perspective if you can
take profits out and pay 21% instead of
35% you are incentivized not to invest
in the business a
higher corporate tax rate actually
incentivizes investment because you're
avoiding more taxes by either spending
on capital investments or your employees
it's it's the opposite of what
supply-side economics suggests I mean is
that something you've heard before we
lost a little bit of our connection so I
lost a little audio there but I think I
caught the gist of it here's where
here's the reason that I defer to the
experts so this is a little bit above my
paygrade
so I would look to the the experts to
tell me what the corporate X should be
and I can change my mind in a heartbeat
no but and I know that's got but what
I'm what I'm saying is forgetting about
the experts and by the way CEOs have
said we don't hire when the tax rate
goes down we hire when there's more
demand for our product or service which
actually does suggest demand side
stimulus but if we think it through you
and I just as people talking here both
with MBAs and economics degrees doesn't
it make sense that if you can avoid a
higher tax rate by investing in your
business you'd be more likely to do it
then if you have a lower tax rate which
would incentivize you to just take
profits and pay executives and
shareholders
I don't know that yeah I would not
conclude that to be true I think there
are probably more variables at play
there than than that going back to your
point about I think we both saw a video
where an audience of CEOs were asked I
forget who was in the audience
yeah like Gary Cohen and they said will
you hire and they didn't put their hands
up there's that but there's also been
more interesting in-depth interviews
with CEOs talking about why right but my
point there was if you've asked a CEO
will you invest because of this tax
change only an idiot would say yes to
that question because there are lots of
variables you would invest because all
of the variables light up not because
one variable lines up or Warren Buffett
says this famously - he's like you said
I've remained a decision based on the
tax rate and I think that's true so the
question is does the change in taxes
free up cash that people then have you
know options to do something with and it
seems like it would as
- your scenario where the tax rate would
encourage them to toss more money into
investments because they get a favorable
tax treatment that way so I think it's a
little too hard for we citizens with a
little bit of economic knowledge to sort
out and in general yeah I mean I think
we'll just have to agree to disagree I
think that that this is one case where
we actually do need to just think about
it at the top level which is a reduction
in a tax rate would dis incentivize
investment III I don't see any other way
around it and this is something I've
studied quite some time but to not just
focus on terrorism you gave Trump a
grade a talk to us about that because
that's another really important one I
think yeah you know the trouble with
grading anybody on terrorism is you
don't know what would have happened if
you had a different president right and
that's sort of the trouble the trouble
with all of these these grades is you're
you're sort of holding in your head an
imaginary standard of how the other
person who didn't get elected would have
done things now we have noticed that
there have not been jag antic attacks on
the homeland you know there could have
been more than what we've experienced
let's say that but again you'd have to
give President Obama some credit for
whatever structure we have in place that
identifies and and preempts attacks
you'd have to say that immigration has
gotten tighter from countries that pose
more risk like which country clear leads
well the country is on the banned list
the those colonies actually had
Nationals come to the US and commit acts
of terror well we're not really managing
to the past are we well I'm asking if
you're saying that that has reduced risk
we would say those countries are on the
list for a reason mine my understanding
is none of those countries have actually
had people come to the US and commit
acts of terror so it seems like it's
gone from zero to zero right how many
times says North Korea attacked us with
a nuclear weapon
you don't really manage for the past you
know there were we're not about managing
things that happened in the past but is
the argument that
the past risk of terrorist attacks from
countries should not be considered in
deciding which country should be on the
list that it should not be the only
variable yes okay so it seems it seems
to me that you know if you're plugging
some holes it's there's more more chance
that people will seek a new hole right
so if you're a terrorist you're looking
for all the ways in and plugging the
countries that would be the most porous
because they have the the worst
record-keeping let's say they don't have
a functional government to to give us
some confidence if nobody had ever gone
through that hole and attacked the
United States that has no bearing on
whether it's still our top priority to
plug those holes if they are the obvious
mechanisms people would use once the
other poles are plugged well but you
said when was the last time North Korea
attacked us with a nuclear weapon North
Korean citizens are on the travel ban
list but is are you suggesting that a
North Korean citizen who aren't even
allowed to leave the country would would
use a nuclear weapon against the US I
don't understand how that connects to
Kim jong-un's regime bombing us this is
why I always say analogies are not
persuasive the only point of the analogy
was to say that we don't manage to past
risks yeah we manage to future risks
sometimes the past will tell you
everything you need to know so for
example the past the past of smoking
cigarettes will predict perfectly that
people who do it in the future will get
lung cancer right the past of how of how
terror attacks happen that the past will
tell you nothing about the incoming you
know drone warfare that is in front of
us so you have to you have to manage to
the future risk not the past risk
exclusively and that's why you think
that a travel ban that includes only
countries that have not ever been
sources of terror in the u.s. makes
sense well those are the countries as I
understand it that have the least
ability to for us to do good vetting
along with along with there's something
attractive about them for the class of
terrorists who might be trying to get
into the country
so there's something special about those
countries and you know if there was
something else special about another
country if for example you know we saw
that Great Britain suddenly stopped
vetting their immigrants and we're we're
giving them full citizenship and
therefore they could come to the United
States we probably would we probably do
something about immigration from Great
Britain it's just that that that's not
the case you you mentioned the word
vetting in your report card you said
that president Trump's extreme vetting
while unpopular with many citizens it
has probably reduced risk to the
homeland what extreme vetting are you
talking about I have no idea so so
here's here's what I mean by that yeah
in all like it all likelihood the the
leadership of President Trump has given
a little bit of freedom to the people
who actually do that work so if you're
doing that work and you're saying to
yourself oh my god we went from very
careful vetting or whatever they were
calling it before to extreme vetting
yeah you're probably free to interpret
that as you need to so this Scott I
think is you know on Twitter when we
first kind of started talking about this
you said I must not have read the report
card and the problem that I'm having is
I read it closely enough that I think
that a lot of the stuff here is a little
bit nonsensical including this because
there's been no change to the vetting
policy under Donald Trump period they're
just they're just has been no change and
what you're suggesting here in having
graded Trump and a on terrorism is that
you're just kind of guessing that
because Trump has talked tough on
vetting that some of the people who work
in immigration are maybe working a
little harder I mean it's it's just so
out there that I don't know how we
regard that so so it's really based on
all manage the principles of management
and leadership in other words people do
at people do act differently even under
the same set of rules yeah if their
leadership changes so they don't have to
change the rules they just have to
change how people think righteousness
strength the strength of President Trump
if you're working in one of those jobs
and you think oh my god if I let
somebody slip through because I didn't
put that extra effort in this is really
gonna look bad for me effort there's
very specific guidelines as to what
doesn't doesn't disqualify you from
coming to the United States and and I
just I just don't know where you're
getting you imagine if you were wait
yeah go ahead do you imagine that
there's no gray areas and those those
guidelines certainly the gray areas but
to give someone an a on the basis that
they've probably decided to take their
jobs more seriously it doesn't seem like
a serious argument to me from someone
who again is talking about you know
persuasion if someone made that argument
to you would you find it persuasive
we'll see how you had to change my
argument to something that made no sense
in order to refute it so you agree were
you reworded my argument as trying
harder I had to say that I said that
would make more attention is that a
better set no the if your mindset has
changed from let me give you an example
in the corporate environment if if your
leader came in and said creativity is
really important we're good via the
creative company and be creative as you
can yeah he wouldn't have to change or
he or she would not have to change any
rules but you would start seeing people
acting according to the way they've been
led if you have an effective leader now
because President Trump is an unusually
persuasive leader in the sense that he
does get in our heads you'd have to
admit he gets in our heads in a way
you've almost never seen before in a
huge way yeah the people working in that
environment are almost certainly
influenced by it within the rules even
if the rules don't change because there
is tons of in the normal complicated
world yeah there's just a gray area
after gray area after gray area and I
have to think that those people are
saying I I'm not gonna take a chance on
this this this gray area it is gonna go
to the president's way because I feel
like that's the right thing to do given
his leadership conceptually I understand
it 100% I understand the concept of what
your
outlining 100% I just don't see how it
gets me to grading Trump is an A on
terrorism but I think we just will you
know we're not going to agree well but
but keep in mind this is one element
yeah so the stream vetting in small now
what I'm claiming is that he's doing it
as well as it can be done by putting the
the persuasion on top of the rules that
were already there but we can't measure
how many people were or were not stopped
by this vetting it's not measurable well
listen uh Scott I really appreciate you
taking the time to talk to us I I'm
being totally upfront with you in the
audience this entire Scott Adams Trump
thing it does bum me out because I've
been just such a big fan of Dilbert for
so long I read the bill Burt principle
and all just all the books I loved it
all growing up I was always holding one
of your books in my hand and the Trump
stuff it just makes me a little sad but
at least you've said that politically
you are to the left of Bernie that's
interesting to me and keep in mind that
what I've been trying to do is explain
to the public what they're seeing in
part because I think this Trump
derangement syndrome is literally
dangerous to the country and it was it
was a bomb that was created by the
Clinton team in the anticipation that
they would win the election and the bomb
would be diffused automatically by her
victory when that didn't happen when
that didn't happen
we we ended up with the bomb in office
and so people are seeing this that it is
literally a mental health problem that I
think I can help in a small way by
explaining that there's technique here
and not craziness not evil etc I would
point out that my prediction from a year
ago was that we would see a cycle in
which people would say we just elected
Hitler Hitler Hitler Hitler and that
would give way over the summer of 2017 -
well he's not doing killer things like
like we were worried about I mean not
serious Hitler things but yes certainly
mild Hitler things yeah yeah he's very
incompetent and that and that has now a
completely given way at the end of the
year as I predicted a year ago that
December 2017
you would see a lot of his critics say
and you can see the articles coming out
all the time now they say well we don't
like what he is doing well he sure got a
lot done that is Republican stuff oh man
I just could not disagree more but
that's it that's a that's a good
disagreement on which to end today Scott
Adams people can follow him on Twitter
it's Scott Adams says and there's no
shortage of compelling I think is the
best sort of value neutral way that that
I'll say you're writing on Donald Trump
I really appreciate you talking to me
today
and buy a copy of win big Lee you can
read more about my opinions on this
stuff thank you so much for having me